I think we've been broke for Barack
Obama for a lot of reasons one he's
smart too he has a great voice I mean
like nothing against John McCain but he
got a whiny little voice you know I mean
I admire his history of service and he
seems like a smart funny guy but
whenever I eat whenever he opens his
mouth I cringe you know and Barack Obama
has this deep stentorian voice so no
matter what he says it sounds great so
person i just i'd rather spent four
years listening to barack obama than
John McCain I also think I'm of course
I'm not the first person to say this
just having a sort of a president of
mixed parentage you know Scandinavian
and Kenyan sends such a remarkable
message to the rest of the world and I
think that that in and of itself serves
American interests better than just but
anything else we can do because
isolationism has not served us very well
you know and we live in this global
economy and especially if you if we
expect China and all these other nations
to continue to sort of fund our debt you
know basically underwrite our debt they
have to like us you know at least it
helps if they like us especially on them
you know on a manufacturing level as
well so I think Barack Obama is just
like a great ambassador for the hood
stages